YOU SAID IT AT PRINCETON.
>> SENATOR, I SAID IT IN MY ROL
IS AN ADVOCATE.
IS AN ADVOCATE, OF RHETORICAL
POINT.
>> SO WHEN YOU SAY SOMETHING
THAT IS INCORRECT, IT'S OKAY,
AND YOU EXCUSE IT BY SAYING I
WAS BEING AN ADVOCATE.
WHAT DO YOU BELIEVE?
DO YOU PERSONALLY BELIEVE CAPS
KILL UNARMED BLACK MEN EVERY
SINGLE DAY IN AMERICA.
>> ACCORDING TO A FANCY NEW
TECHNOLOGY CALLED NUMBERS.
I WONDER HOW SHE RESPONDED.
>> SENATOR I BELIEVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAS AN IMPORTANT AN
CHALLENGING JOB.
>> THAT'S NOT WHAT YOU SAID
THOUGH, COUNCILOR BRETT.
>> I SAY BEFORE YOU HEAR TODAY
THAT I BELIEVE LAW ENFORCEMENT
HAS A DIFFICULT AND CHALLENGING
JOB AND I ALSO UNDERSTAND.
>> I THINK THAT'S AN
EXTRAORDINARY STATEMENT TO MAKE
WITH NO DATA TO BACK UP.
NONE WHATSOEVER.
THERE IS NO BASIS FOR YOU SAYIN
THAT GREAT AND YOU KNEW IT THAN
AND YOU KNOW IT NOW.
HOW CAN SOMEONE POSSIBLY BELIEV
YOU'RE GOING TO BE UNBIASED ON
THE FEDERAL BENCH.
>> I DON'T THINK YOU CAN BELIEV
THAT SINCE SHE LIKE IT WAS A
FLOAT AND THE THANKSGIVING DAY
PARADE.
SHE WASN'T MAKING THINGS UP TO
STICK IT TO THE COPS.
>> SENATOR, I BELIEVE MY RECORD
SHOWS THAT I HAVE WORKED
ELABORATELY WITH LAW ENFORCEMEN
IN CHICAGO, MISSISSIPPI AND
WALKIE TO SOLVE COMPLEX PROBLEM
TO PROMOTE CONSTITUTIONAL
EFFECTIVE.
>> RECORD SHOWS THAT YOU BELIEV
COPS ARE GUILTY INTO PROVEN
INNOCENT.
YOU'RE RECORD SHOWS THAT IF A
COP SHOOTS A CRIMINAL, IT'S THE
COP'S FAULT.
AND IF THE CRIMINAL SHOOTS A COP
, IT'S THE GUNS FAULT.
I READ YOUR RECORD.
I'VE READ YOUR RECORD AND I
DON'T APPRECIATE YOU NOT
ANSWERING THE QUESTION STRAIGHT
UP.
I WOULD RESPECT YOU A LOT MORE
IF YOU JUST ESTABLISHED WHAT YO
BELIEVE AND NOT TRY TO HIDE IT.
>> BASICALLY HER PAST COMMENTS
DON'T COUNT BECAUSE SHE SAID
THEM IS AN ADVOCATE WITHIN THIS
CASE MEANS A LIAR.
THE QUALITY LOOK YOU LOOK FOR I
A JUDGE, TYRUS, WAS THIS JUST A
LITTLE BIT OF HYPERBOLE OR WAS
IT PART OF A LARGER NARRATIVE
THAT FUELED THE RISE IN CRIME.
>> IT'S NOT HYPERBOLE BECAUSE
LOOK AT THE VIOLENCE THAT IS
HAPPENING AGAINST POLICE IN
WOMEN ACROSS THIS COUNTRY.
THOSE WORDS MATTER.
AND USUALLY, HE GOES OFF AND HI
WILLARD LITTLE PLACES, BUT HE
WAS DEAD ON.
I THINK, AND IT GOES BACK TO
WHAT IS THAT A COUPLE OF NIGHTS
AGO THAT WE DIDN'T NEED TO
REDEFINE WHAT WORDS ACTUALLY
MEAN BECAUSE I DIDN'T KNOW
ADVOCATE MEANT I COULD SAY
WHATEVER I WANT.
CAN YOU IMAGINE YOU'RE IN COURT
AND EXCUSE ME, EARL, WHY DID YO
BURN DOWN TYRUS HOUSE?
>> I DID THAT AS AN ADVOCATE FO
THE PLAN.
THAT WASN'T ME.
WELL, CASE DISMISSED, HE WAS AN
ADVOCATE.
AS LONG AS YOUR ADVOCATING, YOU
CAN SAY WHATEVER YOU WANT.
I THINK JUST THE FACT THAT SHE
SAID THAT WITH A STRAIGHT FACE
IS SHOCKING.
IT GOES BACK TO THE SAME THING.
THEY WILL SAY ANYTHING, BUT THE
DON'T WANT ANY RESPONSIBILITY
FOR ITS.
IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE TRUE AND
IF YOU CALL THEM ON IT, HE'S TH
BAD GUY, HE IS BEING RACIST.
>> HE ATTACKS HER.
>> A WOMAN OF COLOR.
>> BUT HE WAS AN ADVOCATE.
>> HE WAS AN ADVOCATE FOR
MISOGYNISTIC MAIL.
ADVOCATING.
>> WHAT IF SHE HAD ACTUALLY
TRIED TO DEFEND HERSELF?
WHEN HE WAS GOING I WOULD
RESPECT YOU MORE IF YOU WOULD
JUST TELL US.
BUT THEY NEVER DO.
THEY JUST BACK UP AND THEY JUST
GO OUT, THEY HAVE THEIR CANNED
STATEMENT.
I WISH THEY WOULD JUST ADMIT IT
IT WOULD BE SHE SHOULD SAY OKAY
LOOK, I WAS VERY SO I MADE STUF
UP AND WILDLY BECAUSE IT WAS
JUST THAT SEASON AND IT MADE ME
FEEL GOOD.
THAT WOULD BE HONEST.
INSANE LOOKING BACK ON IT I
REGRETTED.
>> LOOKING BACK, I WAS BEING
STUPID.
BUT THEY DON'T.
THEY JUST SAY OH, THAT WAS AN
ADVOCATE SPEECH OR WHATEVER.
THE PEOPLE WHO LIE ABOUT THIS
COUNTRY PLAY ABOUT THE COUNTRY'
HISTORY IN WHATEVER THEY GOT OU
OF IT.
THEY WON'T OWN IT.
>> AND, SHE MAY RUN AND UP
BECOMING A JUDGE UNLIKE YOU,
TRUTH TELLER.
>> I'D BE A GREAT JUDGE GREAT
GIG YOU'RE PLAYING THIS LITTLE
GAME.
YOU STILL HAVE TO GO TO LAW
SCHOOL.
>> BUT THAT'S DUMB BECAUSE I
COULD DO LAW.
>> VERY JUDGMENTAL.
>> I COULD BE LIKE OKAY, YOUR
GOOD IN YOUR NOT GOOD.
>> THAT'S HOW I WOULD SAY IT'S
GREAT AS AN ADVOCATE SHE'S AN
ADVOCATE, SHE'S ALSO BAD AT THA
BECAUSE THERE ARE REAL
CONVERSATIONS WE SHOULD HAVE
ABOUT RACIAL DISPARITY IN THE,
BUT THE BEST WAY TO DO THAT IS
DEFLECTED FULL OF OBVIOUSLY
FALSE STUFF LIKE WHAT SHE SAID
SO THEN THE CONVERSATION BECOME
ABOUT THAT.
IT SHE WAS AN ADVOCATE, YOU
WOULD WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
TRUTH.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY NOBODY
CAN EVER JUST SAY YEAH, NOBODY
CAN EVER SAY THAT.
I SAY IT ALL THE TIME.
>> WILL WHEN YOU DO.
>> AND GLAD TO KNOW THAT.
>> OR, YOU COULD JUST SAY I
ADVOCATE.
K GATE THEY FOUND STUDY THAT
PULLED DEMOCRATS AND THEY
BELIEVE THOUSANDS OF UNARMED
BLACKMAN OR MURDERED EVERY YEAR
AND WHERE DID THIS COME FROM?
IT CAME FROM THIS KIND OF
COMMENTARY FROM PEOPLE THAT ARE
SUPPOSED TO KNOW BETTER.
SO SHE HAD BLUEBLOOD ON HER HAND
.
>> SHE ALSO COULD'VE SAID I'M
NOT THE FIRST PERSON TO SAY THAT
.
BUT, I THINK I OWE AN APOLOGY
OUIJA TO THE INTELLECTUAL
HEAVYWEIGHT AS THE WOMAN IN THE
FIRST SEGMENT.
IT'S QUITE AMAZING ALTHOUGH THE
USED SIMILAR LOGIC BECAUSE MARY
POPPINS LADY, SHE WAS CHALLENGE
PEOPLE SAID, BUT SHE GAVE THIS
INFORMATION OUT ON HER TWITTER
FEED AND WHEN SHE WAS LIVE
TWEETING THE DEBATE AND SHE SAI
THAT THE HUNTER LAPTOP WAS
DISINFORMATION.
SO SOMEONE CALLED HER OUT ON IT
IN HER I WAS LIVE TWEETING.
I WAS ADVOCATING.
>> BUT YOU KNOW, MAYBE I DO THA
TOO.
IF I SAY SOMETHING THAT'S LIKE
KNOW, LIKE ON TV, YOU CAN SAY
THINGS AND BE LIKE DUDE, I'M ON
TV.
>> I HAVE LITERALLY NEVER HEARD
YOU SAY THAT.
>> IF YOU'RE WRONG, YOU WILL
HAVE A FOLLOW-UP MONOLOGUE
TALKING ABOUT IT.
>> BASICALLY I DIDN'T.
>> YOU REALLY DON'T ADVOCATE FO
ANYTHING.
>> HE ALSO DOESN'T WANT TO GIVE
THAT KIND OF CONSIDERATION.
>> WHEN SHE'S IN HER BUBBLE,
THEY ALL SAY THAT.
THEY TEAR EACH OTHER ON FOR ITS.
>> I WAS DRUNK AS A VALID EXCUSE
.
>> I WAS ADVOCATING FOR BEER.
I DON'T THINK JUDGES CAN SAY I
WAS DRUNK.
>> YOU CANON WHY COURT.
THE KAT TIMPF DRINKING COURT.
I FEEL THE KAT TIMPF DRINKING
COURT WHERE THEY DRINK WHILE
THEY SETTLE DISPUTES.
>> THEY'RE GUILTY.
>> UP NEXT.
A TWEET FROM A TWIT IN